refroidir phocéenne dorado journalistes
espagnols bonsoir point de fausser
dorado merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors avant de s'intéresser à la
fermeture des établissements nuit quelle
est la situation actuelle en catalogne
est il de l'inquiétude pour la
population au vu de la recrudescence des
quêtes coronavirus il ya de l'inquiétude
forcément puisque effectivement la
catalogne avec l'aragon qui juste au
nord à côté et céline des régions les
plus touchées
en espagne les dernières 24 heures s'est
pratiquement 1500 personnes que tu étais
déclarés positifs au coronavirus donc
effectivement l'inquiétude monte
d'ailleurs c'est à cause de ces
effectivement que des mesures drastiques
ont été prises en catalogne catalogne
aujourd'hui qui voient avec une grande
inquiétude d'une grande préoccupation la
situation sanitaire
alors comment était accueilli cette
décision de fermer les établissements
nuit en catalogne
malheureusement effectivement pour les
professionnels de la nuit 90% à 80% des
personnes et des professionnels des dès
la nuit sont contre cette décision de
forcément puisque pour beaucoup d'eux
c'est la survie des leurs de leurs
affaires et qui est qui et qui est en
jeu c'est vrai que la situation exigeait
des mesures drastiques puisque comme je
vous disais en 24 heures c'est plus des
miss a autour de 1500 cas positifs qui
ont été déclarés en catalogne on ne peut
plus continuer de la même façon
puisqu'on voit qu'effectivement les
foyers d'infection en catalogne se
multiplient aujourd'hui 7 des façon
générale en espagne il ya à peu près 200
foyers qui sont actifs depuis de foyers
tout petits avec une deux personnes
jusqu'à des foyers avec plusieurs
milliers comme ceux les cas du côté des
dés la catalogne mais l'inquiétude
elle est surtout économique puisque
effectivement c'est un dur c'est un dur
à venir qui étant tous ces
professionnels
mais la population effectivement ab soit
a besoin d'être rassuré et être rassurés
c'est de revenir une certaine forme de
confinement ou au mois un contrôle des
mouvements qui s'imposent
oui on sait que le tourisme est
primordial pour l'économie espagnole est
ce qu'on peut imaginer que le
gouvernement referme ses frontières et
imaginait même un recond finement
possible pour l'espagne
il paraît impossible qu'il y ait une
fermeture des frontières comme on en a
connu dans les mois qui sont déjà qu'ils
sont déjà passés d'ailleurs le
gouvernement espagnol le gouvernement
français sont en contact on essaye d
éviter effectivement sera complètement
parce que si les déclarations du premier
ministre font c'est qu'ils ont été pris
on était ont été très mal pris du côté
de la catalogne mais tout simplement
parce qu'effectivement des conseillers
et des milliers des français qui ont
l'habitude d'aller au catalogue naples
n'est plus le fait de fermer la
frontière ça serait un message est
strict et nous vraiment très très très
négatif
il faut tout simplement se rappeler que
déjà la belgique a interdit de visite et
de 2,3 en droit en catalogne et là je
parle d' interdiction de voyager en
catalogne pour à certains endroits ou
encore la norvège qui est tout
simplement impose aujourd'hui une
quarantaine pour tous ceux qui
viendraient d'espagne donc en norvège
donc le fait effectivement que la
frontière sont fermées ça serait
économiquement très difficile à
supporter et socialement et spécialement
compliqué pour une population qui
effectivement a beaucoup des contacts
avec la france
tout simplement un chiffre depuis une
semaine les commerces de la frontière
entre la france et l'espagne disent que
c'est entre 30 et 40 % de leur activité
et qui est tombée des puits qui
effectivement les foyers et sont devenus
beaucoup plus actif en catalogne alors
c'est quoi rapidement c'est quoi la
solution finalement c'est que tous les
pays européens se mettent d'accord sur
les pays à risque pour éviter justement
se re confinement et pour laisser les
frontières ouvertes
la première des solutions c'est
qu'effectivement le gouvernement met en
commun une décision pour tous mais la
première la première décision c'est
celle des citoyens qu'ils soient
espagnols que ce soit font c'est qu'ils
se trouvent foulard cachant où qu'ils se
trouvent au catalogue des retables ir
les gestes barrières délimitent et la
mobilité
effectivement c'est peut-être la
première des mesures on sait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça qui marche et
même si c'est dur il va falloir
s'habituer à nouveau à changer notre
style de vie
merci beaucoup prendre fin dorado
d'avoir répondu à nos questions rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste espagnol